you've likely seen videos on youtube
telling you the number one programming
language to learn right now if you want
to be rich that's not what we're doing
today instead we're going to travel to
the deepest darkest depths of the
software engineering field to discover
the programming languages that are loved
hated beautiful ugly and compiled
interpreted useful weird and everything
in between if you make it to the end
you'll have a roadmap for everything you
need to know to land a job as a junior
developer in 2023 or it might just make
you extremely depressed because this
iceberg is just the tip of the iceberg
of what you actually need to learn
choose any language and you'll find
another iceberg within this iceberg that
goes on forever like a mandelbrot set
which ironically you can represent and
code with any one of the languages we're
about to look at before we get started
there's quite a few programming icebergs
out there but this one ranks languages
based on where i think you might
encounter them as a beginner learning
how to code from scratch each level has
its own theme so let's get right into it
with languages that are designed to make
programming as easy as possible if you
know absolutely nothing about
programming the best place to start in
my opinion is scratch it was developed
at mit like some other languages on this
list but instead of typing out code you
drag and drop these blocks together like
lego bricks to represent things like
variables control flow and operators it
makes the thinking process behind
programming much more accessible and you
might be surprised at what you can
actually build with it
long before scratch though we had basic
or beginner's all-purpose symbolic
instruction code which came out of
dartmouth in 1964. at the time fortran
was all the rage but it wasn't beginner
friendly basic provides a bunch of basic
commands like print go to and four and
was included in most personal computers
which made it the go-to option for
people learning to code for the next 50
years now moving on to the next tier we
have the extremely popular dynamic
high-level languages the language most
people start with today is python
primarily because of its minimal syntax
it doesn't require curly braces
semicolons and stuff like that and
instead uses indentation to represent
different blocks of code the other
popular high-level language is
javascript syntactically it's pretty
ugly but it's a requirement if you want
to do web development and almost every
developer will have to touch it at some
point in their career any application
that can be written in javascript will
eventually be written in javascript now
after learning one of these languages
you'll be able to build pretty much
anything you can imagine and you could
have an entire career as a software
engineer without going any further down
the iceberg but you don't want to be on
your deathbed wondering if you should
have tried out php on this next tier we
have languages that are extremely
popular but a little more specialized
programmers like to get things done from
the terminal and there are scripting
languages like bash and powershell that
allow you to interact with your computer
programmatically instead of typing out
the same commands over and over again
write a bash script to make it
reproducible now if you get into web
development you'll also need to learn
html and css which when combined
together arguably form a turing complete
programming language they're not used
for programming in the traditional sense
but rather to define the structure and
style of a website and if i were to say
html is not a programming language i
would be immediately canceled by the
tech community in addition most apps
need a database and the most common
language for working with databases is
structured query language you can call
it sql sql or squeal this turn complete
although not used for regular
programming but rather to read and write
data in a relational database now python
is great and all but there are many
other dynamic languages that might be a
better fit for certain projects like php
made it easy to build server-side web
apps in the 90s and is still very
popular today lua is easier and faster
than python and is embedded into many
engines like roblox and world of
warcraft ruby is an easy to learn object
oriented language also commonly used to
build web apps with the rails framework
if you work in data science you'll come
across r which is used for statistics
and data vis or julia a more modern
option also used for scientific
computing the one thing all these
languages have in common is a dynamic
type system however as you build more
complex software you may realize that
you need a more rigid framework and one
way to accomplish that is with a static
type system this tier makes up the bulk
of production code out in the world
first up we have java which kind of
revolutionized programming with the java
virtual machine it compiles to bytecode
that runs on the jvm and that allows
developers to target any computer
architecture from a single codebase
syntactically it's an absolute dumpster
fire for beginners i made an entire
video about why people hate java but
having explicit types in your code can
make it much easier to understand and
refactor and modern ides like intellij
will pretty much make the code write
itself java is legendary but it was
followed up by microsoft with c-sharp
it's similar to java in many ways but
gets a lot more love from its users it's
used to build games with unity as well
as web and desktop apps with the.net
framework another well-loved tool from
microsoft is typescript it takes
javascript and adds a type system on top
of it making it much easier to work with
on large complex projects if you're
building a mobile app today you'll
likely be working with kotlin for
android swift for ios or dart with the
flutter framework these languages are
all statically typed but they go about
it in a more modern concise way with
features like type inference that
minimize boilerplate code next up we
have go which is a high performance
language developed at google to build
low-level systems it was designed as a
replacement for c and ken thompson one
of the original creators of c helped
design it the syntax is nice and concise
making it approachable to beginners and
it has a garbage collector which means
unlike c developers don't need to worry
about manual memory management okay so
at this point we've reached the level of
the iceberg where most people are afraid
to go any deeper things are gonna get
weird what happens is that many
developers get jaded with these big
heavy object-oriented languages and go
searching for a better way at this level
we have functional languages the most
famous of which is haskell instead of
classes inheritance and all kinds of
crazy design patterns the only
abstraction you really need is the
function it was inspired by the miranda
language and is named after the
mathematician haskell curry most
importantly variables are immutable and
functions have no side effects
surprisingly you can build almost
anything with these limitations although
most production code out there is not
functional most of us run into problems
when trying to figure out what a monad
is which in layman's terms is just a
monoid in the category of n-functors
haskell is great but microsoft developed
a functional sister language to c-sharp
called f-sharp unlike haskell which is
purely functional f-sharp is also
imperative and object-oriented making it
more approachable to developers coming
from higher up in the iceberg now if you
hate java a good alternative is scala
like f-sharp it supports both
object-oriented and functional
programming but it runs on the jvm it's
statically typed but there's another jvm
language called clojure that is both
functional and dynamic and this makes it
more well suited for getting things done
quickly with the trade-off of type
safety other popular functional
languages include ocaml which is used
extensively at facebook and elixir which
has a very nice ruby-like syntax and is
capable of building high-performance
real-time web apps there's also elm
which is a purely functional language
that compiles to javascript which can
build front-end uis with zero runtime
errors but now it's time to go one level
deeper to the heart of the iceberg these
languages are absolute chats they're
low-level systems languages that can
manually manage and optimize memory and
are used to build things like operating
system kernels and compilers that make
all the other soy-based languages
possible the most legendary of which is
c it was used to build the windows mac
and linux operating system kernels and
its curly brace syntax inspired many
other languages on this list
surprisingly it's not all that hard to
learn and has a relatively small set of
keywords to memorize however being able
to use it effectively requires extensive
knowledge of algorithms and computer
architecture for example c doesn't have
hash maps or dictionaries so you'll have
to learn how to code up that data
structure on your own c was the perfect
programming language when it came out in
1969 but it only supported procedural
programming and eventually developers
wanted more c plus was originally a
super set of c designed to extend it
with object-oriented programming
patterns like classes and inheritance
unlike c it's extremely hard to learn
and provides many opportunities to not
only shoot yourself in the foot but blow
your entire leg off this is a reference
to manual memory management with
pointers which got that name because
they're just as dangerous as pointing a
gun at someone despite its learning
curve it's an extremely prolific
language used to build highly optimized
software like game engines compilers and
so on d and c plus are still extremely
relevant today but the modern chad tends
to prefer rust for low level programming
it doesn't have a garbage collector but
unlike cnc plus plus it uses a technique
called borrow checking instead of
pointers for memory management this
makes it much easier to write memory
safe programs and consistently ranks as
the most loved language in the world the
languages on this tier are extremely
popular but now we descend further into
the modern languages that you probably
haven't heard of first up we have v
which is a high performance systems
language that feels very similar to go
but unlike go it doesn't use a garbage
collector and unlike rust it doesn't do
borrow checking but it can still create
memory safe applications with its own
auto free innovation where the compiler
basically cleans everything up i have no
idea how it works but it looks cool
another modern replacement 4c is zig
it's designed to simplify low level
programming by eliminating features like
macros and meta programming and is very
explicit when it comes to memory
management and it can cross compile cnc
plus plus just like clang zig is not to
be confused with nim another high
performance language that's very
expressive like python but is statically
typed and interestingly it has a tunable
garbage collector that can be turned off
altogether to enable manual memory
management recently google announced
carbon designed to be a successor to c
plus plus what makes it special is that
it can fully interop with a legacy c
plus code base another low-level
specialty language is solidity it's a
statically typed object-oriented
language but is designed for
implementing smart contracts especially
on the ethereum blockchain then we've
got hack from facebook which is designed
to interop with php the original website
was built with php but they needed a
language with better performance and a
type system to scale it up to the
monstrosity that it is today there are
many other good modern languages at this
point in the iceberg like crystal hacks
and pharaoh just to name a few but now
it's time to go down to the next level
where we look at languages that are
still either widely used or historically
important but not something you would
likely choose to program in fortran was
the first high-level programming
language and was by far the most popular
language for many years intel c came
around not long after fortran lisp was
invented in 1958 it pioneered many ideas
we take for granted in computer science
today like dynamic typing higher order
functions recursion and repel it
inspired many other languages like
racket scheme closure and to a certain
extent javascript another highly
influential language that came out this
year was algorithmic language it's a big
complex language and never got as
popular as fortran but its type system
and use of expressions had a major
influence on the development of c and c
plus plus the following year in 1959
cobalt was born if you want to make
money in the 2020s learn cobol because
over 40 percent of banking systems still
use it with over 200 billion lines of
code in production today in 62 apl first
appeared which stands for a programming
language it implements linear algebra
directly into the language with a
multi-dimensional array or matrix being
the central data type this leads to
extremely terse code that resembles
mathematical notation and makes heavy
use of the greek alphabet in 1970 pascal
was invented and took the programming
world by storm it's a procedural
language with a familiar syntax and also
had very fast compile times it
eventually became the most popular
language in the early 1980s before the
rise of c a few years later there are
many other important languages from this
time period like simula the first
object-oriented language that went on to
inspire small talk which itself inspired
many other object-oriented languages
like python java and ruby then there's
erlang a concurrent functional
programming language that basically
powered the entire telecom industry and
is still in use today there's ada a
general purpose language named after ada
lovelace who's generally considered the
world's first computer programmer it was
extremely popular in the 1980s and is
still used today by the department of
defense to blow people up in addition we
should mention prologue the language
that pioneered logic programming and
meta language which pioneered the
polymorphic type system used by other
statically type functional languages
like haskell there are many other
historical languages we could talk about
but now it's time to descend into the
realm of the esoteric where we find rare
and bizarre languages that feel more
like works of art than engineering tools
the first known esoteric language came
out in 1972 and was called intercal
which stands for compiler language with
no pronounceable acronym it was designed
as a parody to make fun of the languages
of the day like algol and fortran it has
an entire paradoxical reference manual
that makes no sense and has an
interesting choice of keywords like
please and mingle please doesn't
actually do anything but it makes you a
more polite programmer next up we have
brain brain is most well known for being
extremely minimal urban mueller created
breakback in college and it works by
initializing an array then gives you a
pointer and eight different characters
to manipulate memory in that array this
results in a code base that will [ __ ]
your brain up it inspired another
language called male bulge or maybe it's
malbulgia which is named after the
eighth circle of hell in the divine
comedy or dante's inferno if you thought
brain was difficult this language takes
things to a whole nother level it makes
programming so difficult that i can't
even summarize how it works in a single
sentence if that's a little too dark a
far more fun language is chef which is
stack based and is designed to make your
code look like a cooking recipe instead
of concise keywords it uses sentences
like put ingredient into mixing bowl to
push a value onto the stack put these
commands together to create a hello
world souffle then specify how many it
serves to write it to the standard
output that's pretty cool but it may
seem kind of silly to an intellectual
the shakespeare programming language
will make your code look like a
shakespearean play it provides the low
level control of assembly with the
verbosity of 16th century poetry but if
words aren't really your thing then a
good language choice would be piet which
is named after piap mondrian it's also
stack based but you write code utilizing
patterns of 20 different colors on a
bitmap image the end result is a code
base that looks like abstract art now if
you're a crazy cat lady you're really
going to love this next language lol
code which provides a developer
experience similar to an llcap meme you
open a program by saying hi then end it
by saying k thanks bye loops can be
performed with i'm in your or broken out
of with i'm out of year that's nice and
easy to understand but it would be even
better if it included emojis emoji code
is a language where the syntax is
entirely based on emojis modern
developers like to use so many emojis in
their documentation that this language
would just streamline the entire process
it's a fully featured object-oriented
language where you can define code
blocks with grapes and watermelons
classes with rabbits and generics with
shells and eggplants another language
that's not necessarily esoteric is c
minus minus it's designed as a portable
assembly language that borrows heavily
from sea but omits many of its features
the ultimate dialect of c though is holy
see which was created by terry a davis
used to build temple os an operating
system written under the direction of
god holy c is actually really cool
because it works like c but it's just in
time compiled on the operating system
which means you can use it like a
scripting language that can interact
directly with the operating system
kernel and that brings us to the final
tier the absolute lowest level you can
go with your learning as a software
engineer assembly is a language of which
there are many variations that
correspond directly to the architecture
on the cpu different cpu architectures
like x86 and arm require different
machine code instructions assembly
allows you to represent this code with
simple commands that manipulate values
on the cpu's registers now if that looks
too easy the next level down is machine
code at this point we're looking at ones
and zeros or raw binary usually
represented in hexadecimal format to
code at this level you'll need to have
intimate knowledge of the computer's
architecture and also be able to count
in binary but if we go beyond machine
code now we're looking at billions of
transistors on a cpu a single transistor
represents one bit like a one or zero by
controlling the amount of electricity
that flows through a piece of silicon
now in order to do anything useful the
transistors need to be organized into
logic gates like not and or exclusive
ore and so on ultimately it's these very
simple chunks of logic that perform the
miracle of taking some electricity as an
input that can produce some other
electricity as an output and do it
billions of times per second all over
the world so you can play video games
with your friend in vietnam if that was
too easy then you may want to look into
the field of quantum electrodynamics you
fully understand how these particles
behave in the electromagnetic quantum
vacuum you can then use your skills to
build a next-gen blazingly fast quantum
computer and become the richest person
in history at this point in the iceberg
there's only one place left to go the
scariest place of all yourself once you
know everything the question becomes
what is knowledge epistemology is the
theory of knowledge and philosophers
still don't have a good answer to this
day reality only exists within my own
mind for all i know the entire external
world and all the knowledge i've
acquired are just illusions and
projections from my own ego maybe
there's a god-like being that controls
all the sensations and knowledge
received by my mind or perhaps my real
body isn't a vat of goo and i'm already
living in zuckerberg's metaverse or
maybe i never came out of that ayahuasca
trip i took 10 years ago the only thing
i really know is that i know nothing
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one